another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with the foundation no  using scps to affect the outcome on  american idol or any other reality show  competition previous violations of this  rule have included showing his least  favorite american idol contestant  scp-096 his face in the hope that it  would hunt him down sneaking scp-348 to  a hell's kitchen contestant and  releasing scp-049 into the house on the  bachelorette because quote none of them  are good enough for rachel so they all  deserve to die dr bryant is to be  reminded that if he cannot stay on his  best behavior and stay out of the  competition his tv privileges will be  revoked and does he really want to risk  missing the latest season of love is  blind i didn't think so